bonjour à tous pour le troisième épisode
de ma série crétin de cerveau consacré
aux biais cognitifs
on va parler des coûts irrécupérable
alors imaginons vous trouvez un super
plan pour un week-end au ski 200 euros
tout compris
du coup vous réservez et puis à deux
jours du week end en question vous le
sentez plus si bien que ça vous n'êtes
pas en grande forme à moitié malade et
puis la météo s'annonce franchement
pourri
et là soudain il ya un de vos potes qui
vous appelle et qui vous propose de
venir plutôt passer le week-end chez lui
avec des amis à regarder l'intégrale de
game of thrones ambulant de chocolat
chaud alors vous hésité un peu c'est
vrai que ce serait hyper sympa ce
week-end série mais bon vous avez déjà
réservez votre week-end au ski et ça
serait con de gâcher 200 euros du coup
vous refuser la proposition et vous
allez ce qui est hélas comme prévu ben
c'est nul il fait froid vous rentrez à
moitié le malade la neige est pourri
ouais mais bon au moins vous avez pas
gâcher vos 200 euros enfin vous êtes sûr
en vous forçant à léo week-end ce qui
pourrit pour pas gâcher vous commettez
une erreur de raisonnement celle dite
des coûts irrécupérable pour décider si
vous allez au ski ou chez votre ami
regarder des séries
il faut prendre ce qui vous fait le plus
plaisir les 200 euros ils sont déjà
dépensé vous pouvez pas les récupérer
donc il devrait pas rentrer en ligne de
compte le choix il est entre avoir payé
200 euros et passer un week-end pourri
au ski et avoir payé 200 euros et passer
un bon week-end à regarder des séries
donc la meilleure décision n'y a pas de
débat c'est le week-end série notre
incapacité à faire abstraction des coûts
passés irrécupérable c'est un bien
cognitifs qui nous fait commettre des
erreurs de jugement et on va voir qu'on
en retrouve un petit peu partout
l'histoire de ski que je viens de vous
raconter elle est inspirée par le
scénario d'une expérience qui a été
menée dans les années 80 par deux
psychologues arx et l'humeur dans ce qui
est la publication de référence sur les
coûts irrécupérable dans leurs premières
expériences ils ont proposé le scénario
suivant à une soixantaine de personnes
arrimage sinon que vous ayez réservé
deux week end au ski 1 dans le michigan
pour 100 $ et 1 dans le wisconsin pour
50 dollars et puis soudain vous réalisez
que les deux tons en fait à la même date
vous pouvez pas vous faire rembourser et
celui qui vous plaît le plus c'est celui
du wisconsin alors auquel des deux vous
décidez d'aller et bien dans cette
situation plus de la moitié des gens ont
choisi le week-end du michigan c'est à
dire celui qui les intéressaient le
moins mais qu'ils avaient payé le plus
cher
comme s'il fallait absolument aller au
week-end le plus cher pour gâcher le
moins possible c'est à dire que 50% des
gens prennent une décision irrationnelle
l'expérience que je viens de vous
décrire elle est intéressante mais ça
reste un jeu de rôle ce n'était pas une
vraie situation les gens répondaient à
un questionnaire et du coup accès
bloomer ont voulu tester le biais des
coups il récupéra dans une situation
réelle
alors pour ça ils sont allés à la caisse
d'un théâtre qui vendait des abonnements
pour toute une saison et la saison
comptait cinq pièces de théâtre et puis
aléatoirement ils ont proposé à certains
clients des réduction sur l'abonnement
1,8 dollar au lieu de 15 dollars et ils
ont ensuite suivi pendant toute la
saison combien de pièces de théâtre les
gens venaient voir les gens qui avaient
payé leur abonnement plein tarif 15
dollars ils sont allés en moyenne voire
4,1 une pièce sur 5 tandis que ceux qui
avaient une réduction ils sont venus
seulement 3,3 fois en moyenne
l'interprétation des auteurs c'est que
ceux qui avaient payé le plein tarif
il se sentait obligé de rentabiliser
leur abonnement plus que les autres et
donc il se force est plus à aller voir
les pièces que ceux qui avaient une
action cette idée fallacieuse qu'il
faille absolument rentabiliser les
dépenses passées pour pas gâcher on la
retrouve dans tout un tas de situations
des situations de la vie courante bien
sûr mais aussi chez les hommes
politiques ou bien les managers des
administrations ou des entreprises c'est
particulièrement vrai quand il ya des
investissements par exemple en recherche
et développement
alors pour tester sa arx et blommer ont
proposé le petit scénario suivant
imaginons que vous soyez le pdg d'une
entreprise aéronautique
vous souhaitez développer un nouvel
avion furtif c'est à dire que les radars
peuvent pas détecter le projet de
recherche et développement coûte 10
millions de dollars et vous en avez déjà
dépensé neuf et le projet est achevé à
90% mais pas de bol un concurrent juste
avant vous sort un avion furtif moins
cher et plus performant que celui vous
avez en train de développer la question
c'est est ce que vous dépensez un
million de dollars pour compléter le
projet sur ce petit scénario fictif le
oui l'a emporté à 85 % c'est-à-dire que
85% des gens décidé de dépenser le
million de dollars supplémentaires pour
terminer le projet
et puis un second groupe de participants
on a proposé une variante du scénario la
situation de départ est absolument
identique sauf que le projet de r&d
coûte seulement un million de dollars
mais il n'a pas commencé et donc la
question c'est est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à dépenser un million de dollars
pour faire le projet est bien là c'est
le nom qui a été choisie à 83% et
pourtant si vous regardez bien dans les
deux scénarios la question elle est
absolument la même
il s'agit de savoir si on est prêt à
mettre un million de dollars pour
développer un avion dont on sait qu'il
sera moins performant que celui du
concurrent alors on peut avoir de bonnes
raisons de le faire ou pas le faire mais
la réponse devrait pas différer dans les
deux scénarios le raisonnement
fallacieux liés aux coûts irrécupérables
et il a tendance à créer des situations
où on dépense toujours plus pour
rentabiliser les investissements passés
et donc on a une espèce d'escaladé coup
même si on sait que le projet à la fin
sera pas rentable
on trouve souvent ça en politique il ya
un cas fameux qui est discutée par arc
c'est plus moeurs et le projet de canal
dit tom aux états unis entre le
tennessee et l'alabama
même après son commencement ce projet il
a été pas mal remis en question et on a
des citations d'hommes politiques qui
défendent est le projet avec des
arguments du genre arrêter ce projet
alors qu'il est dans sa dernière phase
de développement ce serait gâcher
l'argent déjà investi par les
contribuables
et bien non biais des coûts
irrécupérable en france il ya un cas
fameux qui est assez similaire c'est
celui du développement du concorde
même si les gouvernements britannique et
français savaient au bout d'un moment
que le projet serait un échec commercial
ils ont choisi de continuer le projet
concorde pour pagaille
l'argent qu'ils avaient déjà investi
dans le développement le cas est
tellement fameux que dans la littérature
scientifique le biais des coûts
irrécupérable il est parfois appelé
l'effet concorde
il ya un autre exemple politique qui est
très connu ce sont les arguments qui ont
été avancés par certains américains pour
pas se retirer du vietnam et qui donnait
des justifications du genre trop de vies
de soldats ont déjà été perdus et si on
se retire maintenant elles auront été
pour rien et pareil c'est un coup
irrécupérable il devrait pas rentrer en
ligne de compte dans la décision
sur une note plus légère il ya un auteur
qui a étudié l'effet des coûts
irrécupérable sur les décisions prises
par les coachs de basket
vous savez peut-être qu'en nba et puis
dans d'autres sports us est un processus
qui permet aux équipes d'aller piocher à
tour de rôle des joueurs dans le
championnat universitaire ça s'appelle
la draft et donc à une publication qui
montre que à performance égale plus un
joueur a été choisie tôt dans la draft
plus le coach va le faire jouer comme
s'il fallait absolument le rentabiliser
même s'ils n'étaient pas si bons que ça
bon allez assez d'exemples maintenant
regardons un peu les considérations
théoriques
du point de vue de la théorie économique
prendre une décision c'est relativement
simple il suffit de comparer les coûts
et les bénéfices attendus des
différentes options
mais quand on fait ça on doit prendre en
compte que les coûts futurs un ceux sur
lesquels on a un levier d'action
les coûts passés qui sont irrécupérables
il devrait pas rentrer en ligne de
compte
enfin bon ça c'est le comportement
rationnel est ce qu'on vient de voir
c'est que dans tout un tas de situations
et c'est parce qu'on fait on se comporte
de manière fondamentalement
irrationnelle et ça c'est une
observation très importante parce qu'il
ya énormément de travaux en économie et
notamment dans ce qu'on appelle la
microéconomie qui font l'hypothèse que
tout le monde se comporte toujours de
manière parfaitement rationnel prend
toujours les meilleures décisions dans
son intérêt et commet jamais d'erreur de
raisonnement et va devoir que le biais
des coûts irrécupérable c'est quand même
une sérieuse entorse à cette hypothèse
ces comportements irrationnels dans les
choix économiques il en existe plein
d'autres je vous en parlerai dans
d'autres vidéos et ils sont à l'origine
d'un champ d'étude qui est situé à la
frontière entre l'économie et la
psychologie et qu'on appelle l'économie
comportementale
ce courant il a notamment été fondé et
largement étudiés par kahneman et vers
ski dont j'ai déjà parlé dans ma vidéo
sur l'effet d'ancrage
bon maintenant qu'on a constaté ce biais
de notre crétin de cerveau est ce qu'on
peut essayer l'expliquer l'explication
la plus élémentaire c'est tout
simplement le fait qu'on nous a toujours
répété qu'il fallait pas gâcher la wii
c'est vrai de manière générale il faut
pas gâcher
mais là ce raisonnement il s'applique
pas on parle de coûts passent et qui
sont irrécupérables donc y'a rien à
cacher ou à économiser
autre explication au fait que nos choix
soit influencée par les coûts
irrécupérable c'est notre volonté de ne
pas perdre la face alors pas perdre la
face en public un bien sûr c'est vrai
pour les hommes politiques ou bien les
managers dans les entreprises mais aussi
pas perdre la face en privé parce qu'en
fait on déteste se remettre en question
des tests admettre à nous mêmes qu'on a
eu tort qu'on préfère rester avec nos
certitudes passé plutôt que de
reconnaître qu'on s'est trompé
d'ailleurs il ya une expérience
fascinante qui montre très bien cet
effet elle ressemble un peu à celle de
l'avion furtif
on a pris un groupe d'étudiants et on
les a mis face au choix suivant vous
êtes à la tête d'une entreprise vous
avez 20 millions de dollars à dépenser
et vous avez le choix entre un projet
d'investissement à et puis un projet b
et puis on leur fournit tout un tas de
documents de données financières sur
l'entreprise les deux projets possibles
le contexte économique etc et on leur
demande de choisir entre investir dans
le projet house investir dans le projet
b et puis deuxième étape on leur donne
de nouveaux documents qui leur montre
que au bout d'un an est finalement leur
choix était pas terrible les résultats
sont mauvais mais on leur donne à
nouveau 20 millions de dollars qu'on
leur demande de répartir entre
poursuivre le projet qu'ils avaient
choisi initialement et
art et l'autre projet et puis un
deuxième groupe d'étudiants en fait on
leur soumet exactement la même histoire
mais on les fait commencer directement
la deuxième étape
c'est dire qu'on leur explique que
quelqu'un d'autre leurs prédécesseurs a
choisi tel projet que ça a donné des
résultats bof bof et on leur donne
exactement les mêmes documents on leur
demande comment répartir leurs 20
millions de dollars entre le projet déjà
commencé par leurs prédécesseurs et le
nouveau projet le biais des coûts
irrécupérable il nous dit qu'on va avoir
tendance à persister dans le même projet
pour pas gâcher l'argent qui a déjà été
investi
et c'est effectivement ce qui se passe
les étudiants du deuxième groupe
persiste à donner de l'argent au projet
initial et ils allouent en moyenne 9
millions de dollars à ce projet mais les
étudiants du premier groupe e
ils vont donner en moyenne 13 millions
de dollars à leur projet initial
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont encore plus ce
prix que les autres par le raisonnement
qui dit qu'il faut pas gâcher l'argent
déjà investi et pourquoi
et bien parce que ce sont eux qui
avaient décidé d'investir le simple fait
d'avoir été à l'origine responsable de
la dépense initiale nous englue encore
plus dans le biais des coûts
irrécupérable ah oui et le plus
inquiétant c'est que je vous ai dit que
les sujets de cette expérience étaient
des étudiants mais c'étaient des
étudiants en gestion et commerce c'est à
dire ceux qui dirigent les entreprises
aujourd'hui
bon de toute façon de manière générale
le fait de s'y connaître en économie ne
protège pas du billet des coûts est
récupérable
la preuve c'est que arx et bloomer ont
refait leur expérience du week-end de
ski vous savez le michigan à 100 dollars
ou au wisconsin à 50 dollars mais avec
trois types d'étudiants des étudiants en
psychologie des étudiants en psychologie
ayant suivi un cours d'économie et des
étudiants en économie et point important
dans les cours d'économie on apprenait
ce que je suis en train de vous raconter
c'est à dire qu'on apprenait le biais
des coûts irrécupérable et ben voilà les
résultats
environ un tiers des étudiants se sont
fait avoir certes ils ont fait le choix
irrationnels d'aller dans le michigan et
sa indépendamment de leur cursus 1 comme
quoi même le fait de savoir qu'il existe
ne nous protège pas du billet des
couilles récupérables ce biais je le
trouve vraiment incroyable parce qu'il
me semble c'est un des plus puissants
que je connaisse même après vous avoir
fait toute cette vidéo sur le sujet j'ai
encore du mal à me convaincre moi même
je crois que s'il m'arrivait la
situation que je vous ai décrites au
début de la vidéo vous savez wickens qui
versus ce week end game of thrones
je suis pas sûr que j'arriverai à
prendre la bonne décision j'ai vraiment
un crétin merci d'avoir suivi cette
vidéo si elle vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
la partager pour faire connaît
le biais des coûts irrécupérable vous
pouvez retrouver les actualités de la
chaîne sur facebook twitter vous pouvez
soutenir sur tipi merci beaucoup à tous
ceux qui me soutiennent
on se retrouve dans environ deux
semaines pour une nouvelle vidéo avant
une petite pause estivale bien méritée
merci à bientôt